all right y'all do me a favor
rank y'all's top five favorite top the
top five
chicago mcs ever high five
hey so what uh
uh um
mc's bro bro bro what's considered the
mc yeah
[ __ ] rapper man all rapper then like
top five out of chicago do we got it
there
are we showing respect or no as far as
like do i have to like even be like if
you don't dude
i don't really like kanye music but i
mean he's technically
you know like any of kanye's music all
right hey i i i i
this is no order before there's no order
none of this music you got some of the
greatest music ever
oh
if you don't put them up there you kind
of bugging like well
so what's your top five top five in
chicago you gotta i gotta put you keep
up there that's not like
i ain't gonna rank them in the order but
you gotta put them up there if you [ __ ]
with chicago music
i'm [ __ ] with keith herbal
the dirk
i'm so old you got to be wrong if you do
that
kanye you're a liar no but you got to
put kanye up that he's a legend like
and probably as of right now probably
that's the only one i know except for is
one more song but it's not him rapping
he's like a robot
no that [ __ ] like stronger yeah that
[ __ ] that's the only two songs
i focus i just i just ain't
you know i just ain't my type of music
what's your five bro
i don't i ain't gonna go say like top
five mcdonald's i'm saying my favorite
rappers okay
your favorite of all time from chicago
like
uh ain't no order though dirk herb
uh chief keith young pappy
i like a poem that's five that's fine
i'm saying joe like i listen to a lot of
everything shout out to everybody look
can we get me because it's like it's
like it's like
i don't even know who i want to put in
that like i think you're i think you're
melted bro
i'll melt it yeah never melt it we can
get it
we can get started
go ahead what the [ __ ] does that even
mean i don't know what the [ __ ] they
talking about
sorry i don't know what the [ __ ] is to
him
have you guys that's not the point have
you guys ever listened to common in your
life this is just a random question
no no actually i ain't gonna lie i don't
know
[Music]
i think i know who he is i know who he
is what i'm saying i'm talking about
you're from chicago i'm trying to match
his face
[Music]
hey this is the guy from the tyler perry
movies is that oh that's tyler perry
yeah yeah
talking to the [ __ ] mic bro i'll
probably i'll probably be hearing some
comment with my pops
but i can't name one song about comment
though i ain't even gonna lie i think
i think he's too [ __ ] up too far hey
shout out he got like a real serious
flow low key like
i don't know i don't even know
this this is amazing this is my favorite
part of the interview the common
question
that [ __ ] is hilarious a lot of people
know like when you be asking them do
they know
i don't ask i've never asked anyone that
i
and he's been in a lot of movies though
he like a concept
i was getting [ __ ] 20 years ago man
he took ice cubes face off in a battle
i mean ice cube had beef and common put
a song out battling ass man we could
have [ __ ] rap battles
nah bro i used to watch that [ __ ] come
and put it out you know what i called
the [ __ ] in you
and murdered ice cube and then i was
watching
he's like that's another guy in tyler
perry movies right who's right now i'm
not going to actually i'm treating him
i just see some raw battles though and
not a battle battle like how y'all are
used to you know not in the youtube [ __ ]
like they were putting this record
saying that bro i'm saying like a rap
battle you're talking about a rap battle
yeah
i'm talking about ice cube and comments
they drop records on each other
yeah that was crazy they were selling
this record what about twister
y'all listening to twitter i grew up
rocking beds to twist them man shout out
twister joe
i wanna listen to him oh listen to him
no more though hey
oh here okay okay what does that make
you move i [ __ ] around hey keep penny
off that